I want to start by saying
congratulations on the movie I'm sure
you're hearing that from everybody who's
walking in it's real good oh thank you
um so one of the things I want to
commend you on is that literally every
20 minutes I'm constantly saying WTF and
trying to figure out where this thing is
going so did you when you set out when
you cuz you co-wrote this when you set
out to create the film were you at the
beginning saying I want to do a movie
that constantly keeps you guessing yes
and I wanted to I wanted a movie where
every 20 minutes there's a twist but the
thing about the twist is I wanted them
to be so extreme that you'd be like
there's no way this has any connection
with the last 20 minutes I saw and yet
hopefully it does and then as the movie
goes on by the end of the film you're
like wow there's no way this could all
work together and yet it does and that
was really the goal from the beginning
but big fan of movies like old boy and
the handmaiden and these Korean films in
which the craziest stuff happens and yet
it's still all coalesces and that was
definitely an inspiration for this movie
a little bit weird did do you remember
where the idea came from like what would
what's brought it till there's a
sequence in the movie where Alice and
Logan are on a bus and Logan is getting
very sick both physically and mentally
sick and that was when I was much
younger I myself got sick on a bus in a
foreign country and I couldn't speak the
language and it's remained scarred in my
mind and that was the inspiration for
the movie it's like I think this would
be a really interesting sequence
especially if we elevated it it wasn't
just someone just sick but someone maybe
going crazy on a bus what would you do
if you were sitting next to them or your
friend if someone was going nuts on a
bus in an in a foreign country in the
middle of nowhere so that was the
beginning of it but then as we started
writing and developing the movie you
know there was a lot going on we wanted
to talk about some deeper psychological
things some some dramatic stuff some
erotic stuff some bloody stuff we wanted
to get a lot of stuff in there and and
and and that that's what's so fun about
a genre movie that if you're doing it
and you're having fun doing it you can
get a lot in you can get a lot in more
than in a way you can in a drama or a
straight comedy 100% um
did you connect with Netflix to make the
movie and obviously what was the
experience like working with them
Netflix bought the movie after it was
done we premiered the movie at Fantastic
Fest last year and it was like a blast
we got a great reaction and number
people came knockin and Netflix Netflix
is one of them one of the reasons I was
excited about going with Netflix is this
is a movie where too many spoilers ruins
the movie it's not just like it will
ruin the movie and what I liked about
Netflix was it was just opening
everywhere in the world on the same day
it's just gonna come out so if people
watch it and they watch it pretty
quickly they're not gonna have it ruined
by people talking about or whatever and
hopefully then the conversation can take
a whole nother turn so I was excited by
that because it is a movie where the
second time you watch it it's just as
fun and interesting knowing now what is
happened then it is as it is the first
time so I'm excited by the ability for
that many people to see the movie let's
don't fingers press that they actually
watch it know that people are gonna
watch this this is gonna be one of those
buzzed-about movies I'm always curious
about the editing room because it's the
final rewrite so what did you learn when
you went in the editing room with your
footage what maybe surprised you that's
a great question and it's true I loved
the editing because it is like writing
you are in a freer state you don't have
a hundred people waiting for you you're
not running out of time or money you're
in a room for three months create your
movie and you know listen we push things
sometimes too far we should be tested
the movie sometimes the audience got
ahead of us we pulled back sometimes the
audience we lost an audience you figure
a way to get them back I mean it's part
of the process especially movie like
this which is like a house of cards
there's so many different things going
on and if you tip your hand too far one
way or another you kind of ruined the
whole thing so as part of the process of
it I also asked Alison into the editing
room Alison and Logan to come see the
movie as we were cutting it and sort of
helped me because these guys are so
intense as actors and they gave it all
in the film and I knew they would keep
me honest in the editing room too and
one of the things that was super
important to us was so that if you watch
the movie the second time it all makes
sense and works in the confines of the
movie it's a wacky movie so making sense
is a strange thing but all flows
together and making sure that we weren't
making any tricks to make it work the
first time I not the second time so all
of that was a really interesting process
how long was your first cut compared to
the finished film the movies 90 minutes
and it's been 90 minutes almost the
entire time we shot we shot a very lean
and mean script we shot it in 24 days in
two countries in Shanghai and Vancouver
and it was this was there was no access
excess fat on it at all I by the way I
got to tell you 24 days for this movie
is very impressive thank you thank you
yeah I mean we were in it to win it I
mean this was like I the girl though the
two actors learned how to play the cello
we know when everyone was off-book and
knew their lines we did two to three
takes every take every scene like it was
very precise so that we could spend the
time on the scenes that we needed to but
then get through the other scenes that
they didn't need as much time because
this was a lot there's a lot of movie
here and we wanted to be able to to make
it as rich and feel as big in as
hopefully it does Alison mentioned that
you I think you texted her to tell her
to read the script talk a little bit
about what what could he work with
Alison I see with girls what was it
about Alison that that you saw in this
role and talk a little bit about casting
her if you were well I wrote it with her
in mind and one of the reasons is that I
work with her on girls and I loved
working with her but I also saw an
element of her and which she could keep
her emotion hidden and yet still be a
human being it's not so easy actors tend
to give a lot and I wanted her hold back
because I didn't want audiences to know
whether they could trust her character
or not and then I wanted when we did
need to know everything for her to have
it inside of her to be able to do it so
I wrote this character sort of knowing
all of that about Alison plus the fact
that she had been in get out and we
already didn't trust her a little bit
was a helpful thing but you know being
out a write for an actor it's just in my
mind hearing them say the lines I had no
idea whether she wanted to do her in a
knot but I I gave it to her and she read
it and she responded and I think she
really liked that the film was pushing
things and wasn't so easy and then she
challenged me all the way through the
process
she was like this doesn't make sense I
this character wouldn't do this
this seems exploitative this is gonna be
really raunchy and fun but you can't do
this because it's exploitative all this
stuff and it was helpful you know I'm a
I'm a 50 year old man to have a woman a
younger woman too young room with
mclogan giving their point of view
especially in a movie that has like some
complex things going on in their
relationship and in their past I thought
it was really helpful to me completely
my last thing for you when you you had
24 days to make the movie what is the
sequence that you were dreading shooting
knowing the challenges that were in
front of you there's a sequence on the
bus that is basically like a 20 minute
scene and that was the scene that was
the hardest to shoot hardest to figure
out because if I wanted to shoot on a
real bus on a real Road in the in the
middle of nowhere I didn't want
green-screen I didn't want them be on a
soundstage I wanted every bump to be
different I wanted it to be sort of
rough-and-tumble like they talked about
so just figure out technically how we
were going to do it what kind of camera
could we do on a bus that would keep it
stable and then shooting that sequence
was incredible because it was a real bus
in which we were seeing 360 degrees so
it was the cast the actors who played
the people on the bus and five people on
a crew hidden under luggage behind seats
and it really felt it's in a strange way
that kind of like film school it was
such a tiny little crew we had so much
fun and Logan and Allison were able to
do the scene uninterrupted we would just
start it and we do like a seven minute
take and we'd get that coverage and then
we do it different shots of the same
seven minutes but they were able to like
really pick up an energy like when you
do a whole scene instead of breaking it
up like a lot of movies do you can get a
real rhythm and this is a sequence where
Logan is slowly going crazy and when you
do it like that live like that in a way
just really added to it with the bumps
and the fists and no two takes were the
same and yet they they edit it together
perfectly again congratulations on the
movie thought it was so well done thank
you thank you so much for your time
thank you